what does Baby J mean
because where are you calling your tour
from scratch yeah
the tour I was just on is called from
was called from scratch just because I
started calling these shows I did two
months out of rehab I started doing
these shows at uh City Winery in New
York and I just called it from scratch
and there might have been I was trying
to uh say like all of this is new and
please come to the shows but it's going
to be rusty
and it's going to be all worked out and
messy and Etc and then I just kept
calling the tour from scratch I never
loved the name but uh
uh
I didn't want to think of a new one
there was too much going on
there's too much going on in early
sobriety and
I I didn't you know
I just I just kept going with it
but the special is called Baby J which
is something I refer to myself as
special because the people like when 40
year old men call themselves Baby Jake
people find that really cute and like
that a lot yeah yeah do you think is it
like about being like a late bloomer
what is it what what is it kind of in
relation to I don't know I just refer to
myself as it at one point in the special
and it makes me laugh a lot oh nice
um but a part of it is trying to get
back to that before time
like something
a lot of the a lot of the
um tour I just did we used my first
grade photo as the like tour art
and I mean it just was
uh it was it was like you and I were
talking about it but trying to get back
to that age where there was just like
electricity and things were really
exciting yeah and
some you know something went off track
some some things got darker and
now I'm now I was sober and uh
so much of my life had changed and I was
out on the road and I was just I was
like I liked seeing that poster of
myself I like seeing that photo of me in
first grade outside the venue like it
just put me like okay we're trying to
get we're trying to get back to that
we're getting something started chasing
us after that time hmm
something started chasing us that's
interesting yeah yeah that was a thought
I had in rehab like I don't mean like I
heard well I sort of Heard a Voice but
it said we've been after you since you
were a little kid
and I felt like something yeah something
something's been
things of things have had there's been
many great moments but something
's been trying to get your attention
or to get you to get me wow
you think it's like a disease or
something I don't know
some we've been after you
we've been after you since you were a
kid we I didn't care for the Wii yeah
listen I didn't like hearing voices and
detox
I didn't like grinding my teeth I
cracked a molar it was a whole crazy but
yeah I didn't I didn't care for the
voice but if I'm gonna hear a voice I
don't like the Wii of it yeah that's a
lot of people yeah that means yeah
there's a van now you know there's a van
that implies bats guys driving around
with bats
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one